had read now the hall of famer joins us
here on the Rich Eisen show he will be
getting his Hall of Fame ring this
Sunday Patriots Ravens hi ed thanks for
calling in I'm so happy to be sitting in
this chair when you Colin this makes my
day it's just like but this is like my
kind of roster for the day I see you a
crustacean that's where I see you all
the time it's like a gem but I get I get
to share you with Marshall Faulk today
so I'm happy I'm gonna stand in the way
for some of this but I want to know
right off the bat what's your favorite
memory going up against Belichick and
Brady because let's face it you are
definitely Bell Jack's favorite guy that
he ever had to get ready to play against
my favorite memory going up against him
is beating him in the NFC Championship
game to go to the Super Bowl
Marshalls give no luck here here working
at this on junior high school in
Baltimore with catalogs and missing
Tiger man you know what I initiative
here that we do it the junior high
school okay so let's uh I'm just
thinking back to man watching you and
Tom just go at it so just talk about the
epic battles of what you guys had to do
to disguise because the guy has seen so
much
well you know after my cereal proxy
played pregame meal and I got ready to
go Plato's guy everything's falling
apart here um but uh nah man we have to
be right we had some classic battles you
know it was just about discipline for us
on defense really it really has
organization as a team you're going up
against a great organization and the
great team that plays together you know
everybody's pretty much doing their job
that's like the New England thing
through your job you know but that's
what you see on Sundays like so for us
as a defense you know and as Ravens when
I was there you know you had to be on
point man just do what you're supposed
to do because if you don't that's the
one time that that gives the Patriots
you know that window to capitalize on
and that's what they do they're
capitalizing on your mistakes more than
any other team
you know they make more adjustments on a
run than any other organization I would
say you know as a reason why they have
that success you know so you've got to
be on your P's and Q's role to make sure
you you you know you're stopping those
guys Suzie Shuster Marshall Faulk and
Reed here on the Rich Eisen show would
you have liked to have played for Bill
Belichick you know you know I definitely
would have loved the playbook for Coach
Belichick you know I played for a minute
in the Pro Bowl and I was honored to be
coached by man and he saw me on the
sidelines and I can remember him calling
me over there and like it what are you
doing I'm like you know it's not my turn
to be ending in the game that's to Provo
and Marshall can attest to this you know
we are all today and he was like look
here you take out there and do what you
do and that's all he said and what I'm
gonna say coach is not my turn anymore
like
get off the field and [ __ ] rotate on
the other side and I'm gonna be the one
safety this day and all that and when
you look at you you've you've been on
teams you've you've been up again you
went up against Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick when you look at this this
young Ravens team I mean I just just try
to give us an idea of what they're going
to have to do in order to to come up
with the win against the Patriots you
know and minimize mistakes definitely on
beau going on and all facets of the game
man I mean Burstein is offense defense
of life you know this is a very sound
football team that you're planning it's
with the Patriots you know it's proven
they approve it now I'm not saying it
can't be because they can be beat
they've had some tough games you know
they play Buffalo played a real tight
you know so they could be beat but in
order to beat the Patriots you can't you
cannot have a bunch of mistakes can have
a bunch of penalties you gotta take the
referees out of the game and the only
way to take the referees out of the game
is to play smart you know so it takes a
smart it takes a smart player smart team
to beat the Patriots
ed weed here on the Rich Eisen show a
lot of people are saying oh Brady's
numbers aren't the same Brady this Brady
that I can't get over the amount of
haters that come out so early do you see
any drop-off in his game to the game and
Brady is doing he's doing no I'm not
worried about it at all you know you got
and I'm gonna say some things and a
great human being but they definitely
definitely you know should probably be
maybe not even be in the league but I
mean you got a certain quarterback they
put up numbers but did not successfully
not denied of starting quarterback they
just back up you know like a ride
Fitzpatrick you know I know everybody
loved Ryan he's smart he's the backup
he's a good
back up guys you know mad shot you know
I love my shop is a great human being I
love it but there's a football guy you
know we can break number seven back and
he can be successful a lot of other
teams you know I know we offer no car
and card looking good you've been trash
for a long time you know Network that
probably should be there but I was just
think it's really telling I feel we're
gonna talk about mission Tiger and what
I'm doing in the community would care
for I ask you some other questions let's
talk about mission Tiger because I love
that you love frosted flakes my kids
would do anything deed frosted flakes
and I give them all that healthy crap
you love them and mission Tigers and
initiative to give middle school kids
access to sports by supporting middle
school sports programs across the
country with needs from big to small it
kicked out for the 1 million dollar
commitment to donorschoose.org it helped
over 150,000 kids across the country why
did you choose mission tiger you know we
chose each other you know I my
foundation stands for the same things
that I care about in mission Tigers
stand for so this is max in heaven you
know it's truly it's truly the Hall of
Fame things because you know I'm getting
my ring this Sunday and to be doing this
before it you know it's awesome
you know seeing the smiles on these kids
face at the pep rally awesome
Kellogg's gave over two hundred thousand
dollars to the school just to renovate
you know the football fields I mean the
fields the long baseball field which is
co-ed for girls and boys you know and
then getting the whole basketball gym
you know so multi-purpose basketball gym
should I say because they could happen
at often both you know both teams can
practice things that they don't have
this school that we're in right now
kit you team
Academy in Baltimore this school that
we're in is the high school is actually
was given to the junior high you know so
it needs to be renovated they got things
that need to be you know a little TLC
need to be put on you know so for me it
was it's a match made in heaven because
I've been a Kellogg's I've been
Tony the Tiger fan you know I've been
I've been watching them since I was a
kid and they'd be actually taking
pictures with toys and Tiger
you know I'm like like it's real you
know what was your cereal much of it was
your cereal of choice nah we didn't we
couldn't I couldn't afford we had we had
the government cereals King vitamins did
you know each other in New Orleans
no and he recruited me as well but
marched over to San Diego with nobody
wanted my man running back there you go
you know in CJ yeah the same guy who I
was telling you the receivers coach yeah
for the Saints he recruited me to go to
San Diego State recruited him to go to
the University of Miami
same guy so he knows talent when he sees
it he's recruited a lot a lot of really
good players
oh yeah every just about every receiver
that he coached when he was at the
University of Miami went to a league and
prosper not to mention all of those guys
that you saw get developed that the
sinks that you didn't know the Marcus
Colston's devilry Henderson's guys you
know the beginning I got to Hall of
Famers here Edie Reed Marshall Faulk I'm
Susie Schuster here on the Rich Eisen
show I got a question for you last time
you were on the show you said you wanted
to be a head coach and that comes just
hired David Ross to be their manager
he's not managed a day in his life
it happened that doesn't happen in the
NFL
you know I haven't happened yet you know
cancer it's not a thought out there so
it probably it happened at some point
you know but I always hear about you
know just as the gauntlet that you got
to go through as a coach you know like
my resume is not in the NFL for 12 years
you know around a bunch of great coaches
even college from what Marshall was
mentioned to you guys you know I've been
around a lot of great coaches you know
so I don't know I honestly don't know
why you know though I just hear about
that call it you know you got to coach
this you guys do that you got to do this
you know you got guys who's got coach's
job someone worth of a Green Bay now
well I was like he's a head coach like
he was the head coach like this is great
you know baseball and basketball they
figured it out they figured it out
they're still playing is this whole game
of you need to go through getting my
coffee delivering my papers you know
some some guys are they're leaving a
locker room and they've been around not
just not just yeah much as good coaching
but but good players and knowing how to
to elevate people and do things it's
it's you are the have it or you don't
and and I mean you know everybody's
doing a good job with the Yankees up I
mean where did he coach before then yeah
he was color commentating they need to
get off the high horse horse and stop
this and and stop playing this whole
role of what you need to do before you
you can if you can leave me and you can
leave men in a locker room as a coach or
as a player you can leave men that's
true I mean that's it we'll sit you know
if I add anything to this all I would
say is that the NFL is right in the same
way this country is ready you know
there's a reason why that shield is the
same color as I play say more than that
I mean I've said a lot right there and I
think Marshall really
put it in perspective you know I think
he really put you know it put it into
perspective I'll just really you know
summing it up well so as to what it is
you know when I say it's ran like this
country I mean the referees are the
police the referees are the police of
this country once they draw a flag ain't
no taking it back you know and then in
all honesty and just you know giggles
giggles you know to the side you know
once the officer shoots his weapon man
those bullets don't come back you know
and that's what we got to know as people
like you shouldn't put them in that
position as officers just like I tell
players to take the referees out the
game play smart give them opportunity to
totalflash
yeah that makes sense you know and when
you come to the money stuff that's a
whole different conversation we can have
that any time you wanted tell me about
your rings you know you're gonna look at
on Sunday night before you know it now
all the same ring as Marshall is
experiencing you know I'm really just
soaking it up to be in front the home
crowd you know at a big game like this
is gonna be awesome my family's gonna be
here mom and dad my brother's my son you
know his mother you know it's going to
be awesome and we wish you the best of
luck the greatest I'm living the moment
right yeah enjoy it and I
and I'm gonna tell you this the best
part is is going to be the other go
jackets
whom are Ravens of them welcoming you
that's that's like as you got to see at
the hall that experience this is another
one of those once-in-a-lifetime
experience is that I tell people you
can't even dream this this is this this
is so big it's hard to dream what you go
through and the guys that you you become
friends with and just that room I mean
it's it's what this game it's the guys
who built this game love have fun thank
you for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app